Hello, everyone. Welcome to the Lang focus channel.
And my name is Paul people who are interested in the history of English.
Know that English is a Germanic language that developed from old English.
The language of the Anglo-Saxons who began invading and settling in Britain in
the fifth century.
It's also widely known that the development of English was heavily impacted by
two periods of contact with other groups of people,
the influence of old North during the period of Scandinavian settlement and the
influence of French after the Norman conquest.
But there was also another period of intense contact.
When the Anglo-Saxons began invading Britain in the year four 49,
they encountered the Celts who spoke Celtic languages. And unlike today,
lived throughout the Island of great Britain.
Didn't this major contact also have an impact on English. Well,
it's typically thought that it didn't. That's why so few people talk about it.
The traditionally held view is that the Anglo-Saxons massacred the Celts,
leaving them in only a couple of pockets on the Western side of the Island.
That would be Wales and Cornwall, but genetic research, archeological evidence,
and some historical records indicate that the Anglo-Saxons ruled over the Celts,
inter married with them and slaved some of them and ultimately absorbed them
into the population rather than just killing them all or driving them all out
through of course, lots of that happened too, in a situation like that.
It's hard to imagine that English was not influenced by Celtic,
especially since Celts must have formed the majority of the population when
large numbers of people adopt the language of their rulers,
their native language normally functions as a substrate,
meaning that it leaves its Mark on the new language they adopt.
They learned the new language imperfectly with interference from their native
language.
So are there any features of English that likely come from a Celtic language
substrate if we focus on vocabulary then no, not really.
There are only a handful of Celtic words in English from that period.
And honestly, I've never heard anyone use any of those words except for been.
There are however,
a couple of curious grammatical features in English that seem uncannily similar
to features in to Celtic languages. Well shan't Cornish. The first one is,
do support the use of what John McWhorter calls the meaningless do
in English or do is inserted into many yes or no questions and negative
statements. Like, do you drink coffee?
Have you ever thought about why do appears in that sentence in many languages of
the world you form yes or no questions by simply saying a statement with raised
in donation, something like you drink coffee in English. Of course,
in English you drink coffee. It is something people say,
but for a specific purpose to check that they've understood correctly when they
hear something surprising. But in other languages,
that's the regular way to ask a question with no such special purpose,
for example, in it Kalyan, baby and cafe.
This is the same as the statement baby in cafe,
but with raised intonation in some,
there's a question Margaret that goes before or after the sentence, for example,
in standard Arabic, you might add how before the sentence, hello.
[inaudible] or you can say it without the question. Marker.
So it's the same as a statement, but with rising intonation,
that should [inaudible].
And there are other question forming constructions like ESCA in French
literally, is it that [inaudible] you cafe or more formally,
you might use inversion instead? What do you do cafe,
but none of them use the equivalent of the verb do except for two languages.
Well, Shen Cornish Welsh doesn't use the meaningless do in the present tense,
but it does in the past tense. For example,
if it's word for word it,
did you drink coffee the morning?
This notice that this word nest is the past tense of the verb,
meaning do it's also used in negatives in English. For example,
I don't drink coffee in many other languages.
A simple negation word would be added something like I not drink coffee.
For example, in Hebrew, uh Nilo shall take coffee again.
No other languages in the world use the equivalent of the verb do as an
auxiliary in a negative sentence, except for well Shen Cornish.
Here's an example in Welsh.
Coffee, but.
This means I didn't drink coffee this morning word for word it.
Did I not drink coffee? The morning this,
as we saw before this word ness is the past tense of the verb. Meaning do,
but again, in Welsh,
the verb do is only used as an auxiliary in the past tense in
English.
We also sometimes use the verb do as an auxiliary in affirmative sentences in
order to show emphasis like I did wash the dishes, something you might say,
if your spouse asks, why didn't you wash the dishes in Welsh and Cornish?
The equivalent of do is use generally not only to show emphasis, for example,
in Welsh.
[Inaudible] word.
For word it did I wash the dishes?
This could mean I did wash the dishes with emphasis or simply I washed the
dishes without emphasis.
So that might seem like a weak link between English and Celtic because in
English it's only used for emphasis, but it used to be used in the regular,
affirmative and English too. That means it was used without adding emphasis.
It was just a normal way to express the present tense.
Like these examples written in early modern English doubt that the sun doth move
and the serpent that did sting thy father's life.
These are lines from Shakespeare's Hamlet.
Neither of them are in phatic by the year 1700.
This usage had fallen out of use in English,
but until then English resembled Celtic a little more than it does now,
could these similarities be mere coincidence? Well,
that would be a reasonable assumption if do support occurred in various
languages throughout the world. But as far as we know, it only occurs in Welsh,
Cornish and English.
And since English was superimposed onto a Celtic speaking land,
the same land work Cornish and Welsh developed,
then it makes sense that Celtic is the source of that feature in English.
Another odd feature of English is the exclusive use of the ING form.
The present continuous form to refer to an action in the present moment.
If we think about what the present continuous really expresses in English,
it is in a sense,
the only true present tense to talk about what you are doing in this moment.
Right now you say something like I am working out at the gym.
I work out at the gym is not something a native speaker would ever say to talk
about the present moment that refers to general time to something you do on a
regular basis. So how is English special in this regard?
After all lots of languages have a present continuous form, don't they,
the differences that in other languages,
the present continuous form is used to emphasize that the action is ongoing in
the present moment, but you can still use the simple present and it's correct.
It just lacks emphasis, for example,
in Spanish you'll [inaudible] meaning I am eating this
form emphasizes that the action is happening right now,
but it's also fine to say you'll Como, which is the simple present form.
How about in Welsh and Cornish?
There are similar to English in that they use the equivalent of the English
progressive form to indicate an action in the present moment.
One difference is that they include a preposition, for example, in Welsh,
which means he is running word for word it's. Is he in running?
So literally it's more like he is in running in English.
There used to be a preposition like this too. Like I am on running,
which gradually morphed into I am a running and then the preposition was lost
entirely. I am running.
If we compare the older English structure to the current one in Welsh and
Cornish, it's more similar than the current form in old English.
We could say this each Aleme on [inaudible] that's like saying I am on
hunting rather than I am hunting in modern English.
There's more to it than that.
The Celtic progressive is formed with the equivalent of the verb to be followed
by a preposition and a verbal. Now, rather than a participle in English,
there were originally two ways to form the progressive a participle ending with,
and day. For example,
each [inaudible] like I am hunting and a verbal Mt.
Structure. Each Aleme on [inaudible]
. Other Germanic languages have retained their equivalent of the end day
participle, but in English it came to be replaced by the verbal noun
with ING, which now functions as both the verbal noun and a participle.
So English lost the form that resembled Celtic less and replaced it with the
form that closely resembled Celtic, that much is clear. The question is,
did this happen due to Celtic influence or some other?
Cause the case for Celtic influence seems quite convincing people who question
the Celtic influence hypothesis usually points out that the contact between
Anglo-Saxons and the Celts took place hundreds of years before those features
started to appear in written English. For the most part,
it wasn't until the middle English period that these Celtic racism started to
appear. And for hundreds of years old,
English was written without any real indication of a Celtic substrate.
If the Celts had influenced English, then why didn't it affect old English?
Well,
that could be because of the difference between the spoken language and the
written language English,
as we know it is the written literary language of those days and was certainly
much more conservative than the spoken language isms may have been in common use
amongst the common people.
Wildly elite scribes saw those innovations as a vulgar and continued to write
old English pretty much the same way it had always been written.
Most people were illiterate.
So it was highly unlikely that they felt the need to speak like books or could
have even if they had wanted to. But after the Norman long quest,
French became the language of the elite for hundreds of years and written
English lost its prestige.
It's likely that when English later regained its status,
it was free to be written as it was really spoken because literary old English
had been left unused for a long time.
So the Celtic elements that had been part of spoken English all along were now
suddenly part of the written language too. So what do I think? Well,
I'm quite convinced that Celtic must have had some influence on English and
these Kelda systems that we've looked at are quite compelling.
I do have a couple of reservations though.
First while Welsh uses do support in the past tense,
it does not use it in the present tense,
which makes its link to English seem weaker. English doesn't just have,
did support. It has do support. Also,
there are other ways to express the past tense and Welsh sentences with do
support, can be used for both emphatic and non-empathetic sentences,
but they don't have to be used for either in English do as required in many
contexts. Another reservation I have is that while English has both the present
progressive and the simple present tense that is used for statements about
general time, as well as for state of verbs Welsh,
doesn't use different forms to distinguish between general time and an action in
the present moment. So this makes me wonder,
is it really a progressive form or is it simply the all-purpose present tense
and just structurally resembles the English present? Progressive of course,
nobody is saying that modern Welsh influenced English,
but rather that an early form of Welsh and other Celtic languages influenced
English. So I guess it's normal that the links would have some weaknesses.
Some people are bound to ask why this video focuses on Welsh as a point of
comparison. What about Irish and Scottish Gaelic? Well,
Gaelic developed in Ireland.
So it wasn't Gaelic that the Anglo-Saxons had the most contact with,
but rather protonic languages,
the precursors of Welch and Cornish and Welsh and Cornish existed
alongside English as they developed. So what about Cornish? Well,
Cornish isn't widely spoken anymore and in fact,
it's not spoken as a native language at all anymore,
so it's difficult to find information on it.
And it's difficult to find coroner speakers who can help with the sentences in a
video like this, the question of the day,
what do you think of the similarities between Celtic and English?
Did they convince you that Celtic languages have influenced English live your
reactions in the comments down below a very special,
thanks goes out to my Patrion supporters, especially my top tier,
your patrons who are right here on the screen,
many special thanks to them and to everyone.
Thank you for watching and have a nice day.